it is the end of an era as the last
smash ultimate character has finally
been revealed
we're gonna talk about that and how
kingdom hearts is coming to switch how
you can get into the battlefield 2042
beta early and how ghost recon is
getting a new mode my name is devonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
now i know we're all heartbroken that cj
from san andreas didn't make it into
smash ultimate but let's put that
heartbreak aside because the guy that
did make it is pretty cool mr sakurai
revealed sora of the kingdom hearts
series as the game's final dlc character
and the majority of the 40-minute
presentation was dedicated to showing
off his moves stage musical selections
and more the presentation also unveiled
the last batch of downloadable me
fighter costumes which include
doomslayer from doom as well as an
octoling wig and jut the cat hat from
splatoon these me fighter costumes will
be available on october 18th for 75
cents each and as if those announcements
weren't enough sakurai also announced
that nintendo and square enix are
teaming up to launch three kingdom
hearts games on nintendo switch and
these names are all a mouthful so bear
with me here we go kingdom hearts hd 1.5
plus 2.5 remix kingdom hearts hd 2.8
final chapter prologue and kingdom
hearts 3. these will all be cloud games
that stream to your switch aka you will
need a constant internet connection to
play them
but okay let's talk about some shooter
news now battlefield 2042's open beta is
right around the corner and is now
available to preload the beta will kick
off on october 6th for those who have
pre-ordered the game or subscribe to ea
play everyone else can play starting on
october 8th until the beta ends on
october 10th adding to this dice has
published an faq that runs down the key
details of what you need to know about
the battlefield 2042 open beta and
preloading for instance it will not show
up automatically in your game library
you will need to search for battlefield
2042 open beta on your chosen storefront
and in other shooter related news
ubisoft has announced ghost recon
frontline a large-scale pvp shooter that
carries the tactical heritage of the
shooter but implements it in a first
person multiplayer experience the
standard gameplay mode in frontline
expedition pits 100 players against each
other in small teams of three-person
squads their objective is to find
crucial intel and extract it but must
contend with the other squads to do so
the action takes place on the island of
drakemore which was described as being
four by four kilometer in size and
features four distinct biomes and 20
landmarks one of the key gameplay
considerations that ubisoft hopes will
distinguish frontline from other battle
royale games is the ability to change
the battlefield players will be able to
earn and deploy equipment weapons and
gadgets however specific items such as
turrets cover and even a sniper tower
can also be dropped in
but i remember far cry 2's villain the
jackal well during an interview with ign
far cry 2's creative director clint
hawking confirmed that jack carver the
protagonist from fc1 was definitely the
jackal this confirmation puts a lid on a
13 year old fan theory so if you were
one of those people that was speculating
all these years then congrats you can
rest
and speaking of far cry the sixth
installment is so close to its official
release and similar to fc four and five
far cry 6 features a secret ending that
can be unlocked early in the story to do
this you'll need to get on the boat and
you only have one chance to do this and
drive in the opposite direction of your
objective that's all super simple i
can't wait to play this game and i
wonder which ending i'm gonna like more
so go ahead and hit the comment section
and let me know how hype you are for
sora on a scale of 1 to 10
and if it could have been a different
character who would you have wanted let
me know
peace
[Music]
you